So, init is the most important of the Magic Methods. And nearly, every class
that you define will have init there. I want to introduce one other magic method
now. There are many, many others. We're only going to cover one more today,
which is the str magic method. And what str should do is return the string
representation of this instance. So, here's why str is so useful. Every Python
object can be printed. Say, we can a number and we get three, we can print a
list, we get something that looks at the list. When we print one of our
restaurant objects, well, it tells us there's a restaurant object, but it
doesn't tell us anything useful about it. What's happening when we print things,
the Python internal definition of print is using str to turn an object into a
string, that's str operator like this. Str can turn any object into a string,
and you'll notice that the results here are of type string, or type str. When we
do str on one of our restaurant objects, well, we get back to this string.
That's because we haven't defined a magic__str method. If we do that, we'll get
something more useful. So, let's do that.